[Musik]
wenn sich sarah gierig an die arbeit
macht wird aus schokolade kunst ob die
skulptur eines kraken oder ein bunt
bepinselte clown ihre kreativität setzt
sie auch ein wenn sie schokoladenfiguren
für die weihnachtszeit entwirft
[Musik]
natürlich hier für kinder das paradies
ohne ende im schnee spielen die pinguine
mit dem elch also ich finde zu
weihnachten was immer das gesamtpaket
stimmen also das soll schmecken es soll
schön aussehen und also ich will einfach
die menschen glücklich machen und den
ein lächeln ins gesicht zaubern und
momentan ist halt so da trend auch ein
bisschen das alles schön bunt und
knallig dass man das nennt sich mut für
das man glücklich ist vom bloßen
hinschauen in schokolade stecken
unzählige aromen die herauszuschmecken
ist eine wissenschaft für sich
sarah gierig beherrscht sie denn die
genannte konditoren ist auch schokoladen
familiäre eine expertin für das süße
genussmittel ihre kreationen präsentiert
sie im geschäft ihrer eltern im
sächsischen neustadt erkennt man an der
wunderschönen klang an dem knackigen
bruch muss richtig schön knacken und
beim verkosten ist es ganz wichtig dass
man die schokolade 30 sekunden im mund
behält weil dann schmilzt erst die
kakaobutter und die ganzen leckeren
geschmack kommen können sich bilden wir
testen das am anfang steht die
kakaobohne die nur in der nähe des
äquators wächst sie wird gerüstet und
zurow schokolade verarbeitet die je
nachdem wo sie herkommt immer anders
natürlich muss ich auch immer wieder
meine sinne schulen also man sollte es
wirklich trainieren
ich denke die ganzen wein sammeln jetzt
die machen das auch ganz oft wenn zb
zusatzstoffe einen zu niedrigen cacau
gehalt der schokolade verschleiern
sollen schmeckt sarah gierig das sofort
[Musik]
ein bisschen fruchtig und säuerlich also
ich tippe auf afrika und würde sagen die
hat auch so um die 60 70 prozent das ist
so 65 prozent also tippe ich auf
madagaskar die afrikanische kakaobohne
ist auch eine gute grundlage für
schokoladenspezialitäten in der
weihnachtszeit besonders beliebt sind
traditionelle motive und klassische
geschmacksrichtungen
es war eng in die klischees des
christlichen festes sarah dierichs
kreativität manchmal etwas ein
aber man kann immer wieder etwas neues
erfinden jetzt ist er der neue trend
food gering
das heißt im geschmacks aromen die gut
miteinander kombinierbar sind verbindet
man zum beispiel machen wir jetzt was
ganz verrückt dass also ich habe zehn
orangenöl und da braten wir jetzt speck
an und verbinden das dann mit sahne und
dunkle schokolade machen meine ganz
crazy praline der sud aus speck seine
dill und geraspelten orangenschalen wird
durch ein sieb passiert und mit
schokolade wird fertig ist die füllung
einer extravaganten schokoladen pralinen
doch egal ob sarah gierig schräge oder
konventionelle weihnachts delikatessen
kreiert die wichtigste zutat für sie
mein absolutes geheimrezept ist immer
mit ganz viel liebe machen und alles zu
sagen von herzen kommen und es muss spaß
und freude machen und das ist eigentlich
das wichtigste überhaupt bei meinem
beruf weil wenn es mir keinen spaß mehr
macht dann drückt man das auch und mit
solchen schokoladen variationen wird
weihnachten auf jeden fall ein buntes
fest für alle sinne
[Musik]